[Music]
researchers have discovered 97 new areas
of the brain that were previously
unknown this is fascinating check that
out 97 previously unknown areas these
new regions control different functions
thoughts behaviors in all of us I
thought once again we should take a look
at just a few of them for example the
first new region of the brain allows you
to remember your high school locker
combination
but not the name of the person in bed
with you yeah check yeah this region
this region tells you it's okay to find
the site of old people slipping on ice
hilarious this region allows you to tell
the difference between Michael Cera and
Jesse Eisenberg this region overrides
your judgment of your tinder dates
fragglerock tattoo this region makes you
blow off the gym to watch four hours of
that show about people living in tiny
houses
this region allows you to laugh at the
stupid [ __ ] your boss says
[Laughter]
[Music]
and finally this regional male brain
does whatever the penis tells it to do
[Applause]
you